welcome back just because the gadget is
high tech does not mean it has to be
kept inside joining us now is tech
expert sarah evans
with the latest in outdoor tech welcome
sarah and i think if you have if you got
a cell phone
you're going to want this first item
what is it so i'm a huge fan of this
it's the mophie uv
sanitizer and phone charger retails for
about 79.95
cleans everything that's phone sized in
about five minutes thanks
keys credit cards and it kills up to
99.9
of things like staff e coli covid so
it's really nice to keep on hand
hold on one second so it does more than
just your cell phone you can add your
keys and any other little mobile
items inside that thing absolutely
anything that is cell phone size you can
throw it in there
while you're cleaning you can charge
your phone your wireless charging phone
at the same time
that is perfect your next item is for
for those that like to work from home
what is it
so i love this idea of desk view so that
if you are
vaccinated you're going back out into
the world you can take your desk
anywhere and not have to touch any
tables or any other equipment it
attaches in about five seconds to any
whiteboard
or window so you can create a standing
desk wherever you are
and keep all of your devices together in
your own personal space
that's brilliant too because you're on
vacation you put it up with a window
with a view
and your office i mean the scenery just
changes now this next one
it's so funny cause i cleaned out my
garage over the weekend and i found a
lock
and i couldn't remember the combination
for the life of me this next one your
next item
it's a game changer so i love this
because the same thing has happened to
me throughout the years this is a
fingerprint sensor lock and you might
think wow more
touching items during a time when we
want to be touch free
but it really is applicable just to you
so instead of bringing another key which
would be another touchable device with
you it just reads your fingerprint it
can read up to 10 different fingerprints
um there is a key that comes with it
just in case
you don't charge it so that you can
always have access to your lock
it's it's one of these things where you
say why didn't someone think of this
thing
five ten years ago finger unlock your
lock it's perfect
all right the last the last item we have
i think everyone should have
in their home what is it so this is
something i want to put in my home it's
a sanitizing station these are things
previously you would have seen in
airports or
public locations like hospitals but why
not bring one to your home or outdoors
or the local park you can put it outside
the house
you can bring it on a trip for camping
it's battery powered
and it has infrared motion sensors you
can put your hand underneath it and your
anti-bacterial
lotion or sanitizer comes out so you can
make sure everyone is sanitized around
you it's great stuff sarah someone's
watching right now they want more
information where can they go
they can find me on twitter at pr sarah
evans and i talk about consumer tech
products
almost all day long yes you do and
you're the best at it we appreciate it
thank you so much sarah
thank you mercedes we'll send it over to
you